migratory birds can sense the Earth's
magnetic field they use this inbuilt
compass along with visual cues like the
Sun and stars to help them fly in the
right direction
for decades people have wondered whether
electromagnetic noise made by humans
could be interfering with birds magnetic
compass now scientists in Germany have
shown it in robins at least this appears
to be true
anthropogenic electromagnetic noises
everywhere because every piece of
equipment with a plug when you plug it
in its going to make electromagnetic
noise in some frequency range if you
could sense this electromagnetic noise
it will probably be like some kind of
rock concert going on all the time
Henrichs team discovered this effect
when they tried to replicate an
experiment performed by scientists who
study bird orientation it involved
putting robins in a cage at night during
the migratory season because the birds
are so eager to migrate they'll jump in
the direction they want to fly you take
some birds from their normal home cages
you bring them to your hot where you
want to do your experiments and then you
take them out of the carrying case and
you put them into this funnel and this
funnel has scratched sensitive papers on
the walls and then you leave it there
for an hour where it does it's
spontaneous micro restlessness behavior
which is only dot does at night and in
the micro tour season after this hour
you take them out of the funnel and you
have the results on the scratch paper
for three years Henrik and his
colleagues couldn't see their robins
jumping in the right direction
we were desperate to make this
experiment work so for three years we
tried all kinds of things to make this
experiment work but nothing changed it
they were disoriented until one day a
postdoc of mine knees last night I got
the idea to scream the wooden hots on
the inside with aluminium plates and
connect them to a lightning rod by
screening the hurts with aluminium the
researchers blocked man-made
electromagnetic noise from entering the
hut when they switched the screening on
the Robins suddenly oriented so this is
one of the experimental huts that we use
for our experiments and what's
fascinating is that the grounding down
here can actually be connected and
disconnected just by unscrewing the
screw and this means that if you unscrew
this screw the birds inside this heart
we
be feeling all the electromagnetic
disturbances and they will not orient if
I reconnect the screw so that the
aluminium screens inside are connected
then the birds inside this hot will
orient so basically I can turn on and
off the orientation of the birds by
either connecting or disconnecting this
group once the team had removed the
robins from the cages they could take a
closer look at the scratch sensitive
papers so at the end of the experiment
we collect the papers of the panels and
basically we can then look and see in
what direction this bird wanted to jump
in and go in you can see here that this
bird is very very oriented in this
direction there are lots of scratches
here and virtually no scratches here so
this is a very well oriented bird to
work out what kind of manmade
electromagnetic noise was interfering
with the Robin's compass the team used
coils to artificially introduce
different frequencies of noise inside
the hut so the frequency range that we
found effects off is the radio frequency
AM radio frequency band that's from
about 50 kilohertz to about 5 megahertz
and that means that it's not mobile
phones because that's gigahertz and it's
not power lines because that's 50 Hertz
so it's it's radio signals classical
radio signals it is all kinds of stuff
that comes unintentionally from all
kinds of equipment you connect
[Music]
so how much of a problem is
electromagnetic noise for birds which
migrate it may be a very localized
effect that only affects them as long as
they're in towns and cities and the
moment they're outside of town they they
are fine and one thing is certainly
important to realize again is that birds
have many different navigation systems
and they have backup systems so if the
magnetic compass doesn't work they can
use the Sun compass the star compass
landmarks will still be fine and so on
so we don't know how large this effect
is how exactly Birds sense the Earth's
magnetic field is not fully understood
the leading theory suggests molecules in
the bird's eyes are affected by the
magnetic field allowing the bird to
actually see it as an image but how this
works remains a puzzle so one very
interesting aspect of this study is that
these very these electromagnetic fields
are very very weak in energy so the
energy is so low that we think that the
mechanism that leads to this effect
can't be convey Stahn conventional
physics it looks like it must be quantum
mechanical and we still don't understand
exactly how it will work but we hope we
can find that out in the coming years
[Music]
[Music]
you